last name heart lives on generations now
we got generations of generation is a
good thing that's nice pop a heart
Kevin Hart welcomes baby number three
and opens up to ET about fatherhood at
the Jumanji junket in Hawaii so far the
proud dad is still dodging diaper duty
how long that lasts
it's still going on how much I don't
believe that I I've not changed the
diaper I'm around when a diaper is being
changed
which makes me a part of the process as
long as I'm supportive within the moment
that means I'm there in the moment honey
you got it you do it that you want me to
women aground
I'll go get it oh you got those find
other stuff to do wise going down right
he said he was gonna practice detachment
for you so after one is done that's all
just say bunch of nothing maybe I'm
gonna get the you let me get the car put
your stuff on it what what's hot you
guys put pictures out of him he really
is cute okay I'm not even kidding
yeah no he looks just like his day okay
I have to say he does look like you he
looks like a lighter I don't want to
[Laughter]
what it's been great yeah I have no
complaints that are very blessed very
happy and you know looking to expand his
legacy
[Music]